we were talking about the the positives
and negatives of buying a home because
you pointed out hello as you tend to do
why it's not that great of an idea
necessarily no it's not fantastic it's
good it's fine if you want if you want
to do and you like save up the money and
everything you really look into it but
everyone's told I'll buying a home is
something everybody should do that's the
best investment you can make and it's
like not that great here's why the show
drives people crazy of course we're
talking about Adam ruins everything
yes it's because they'll be this like
one second where a guy goes it's fine
for some people but here's why it's not
fine and you go like 15 minutes about
all the problems with it so anybody
that's like not a hundred percent secure
in their decision it's just watching the
show go you shouldn't be a hundred
percent secure about buying about
spending you know half a million dollars
or whatever people are spending now on
our house you know right so it's the
biggest it's the biggest purchase you'll
ever make you should spend some time
thinking about it but you don't want
people to think that this show just
might be negative things point to that
about things they like no no well at the
end of the show we always have a
positive you know we have a positive we
tell you why it's better to learn the
awful truth about everything you love
yeah yeah yeah but it's like you're
you've you've beaten somebody for 30
minutes and then at the end you go but
you know I love you right fair enough
okay you know he loves me he does love
me it's a good theory on it because you
you get a 30-year mortgage you're paying
like $300,000 in interest over 30 years
yeah not that seems insane like why
would you pay that and you pay all the
interest up front you know people say
all right I'm not you know I'm not
throwing my money away well for the
first 15 years you kind of are you know
you're spending like 80 percent is just
going to the bank unless you're paying
the principal always paying extra into
principal put an extra 100 bucks a month
in the principal that's good you know
but like if people forget about all the
downsides of buy home it routes you down
into one place it makes you less
flexible like there's I forget the
number because we made the episode a
couple years ago but like there's an
amount that people don't take jobs
because right they have a home and they
can't move oh I got a house I can't move
whereas if you're renting you know like
okay you know hey as a comic right oh I
got a writing job in LA sure I can fly
out there I'm on a month-to-month lease
you know or whatever I'll sublet my
place to the lease runs out right if you
if you buy a place you're sort of you're
rooted down there and that's like a
disadvantage that we don't talk about
here's why
like owning though because I'm so afraid
they're gonna take everything from me my
[ __ ] career everything like if I pay
it off and I pay it off I pay if I have
a home I'll always be able to go out and
earn enough to pay like the monthly
maintenance fees yeah you can always
earn that and enough to buy it like the
little repairs you got to do you're
trying to pay it off
I want it paid the [ __ ] off because a
it's less entry like a B they can't
remove that from me if they take
everything else yeah I think most people
though have a mortgage that they
basically treat like rent where the idea
of actually paying off the mortgage in
toll is your total is such a pipe dream
if you get the right mortgage you get a
30-year fixed-rate and you know you
don't like move too often you plan that
way that that can definitely be good a
lot of people get adjustable rate
mortgages you know or they're like
moving all the time they're moving every
couple years and like at that level like
yet you're basically I mean your your
your the amount you pay every month can
go up and down you know it can be pretty
wild so yeah I just dump money and I'm
just so scared of them taking everything
kind of a place to live the house I pay
mine off you know any yeah my money guys
like don't put it in a stock market I go
I'm not paying $300,000 for 30 years in
interest right here's were you gonna
probably make around nine percent in the
stock market if you leave it in there
and you get an interest rate for three
percent so it's stupid a four percent
but don't worry about it I don't worry
about it they told me the same thing and
then the [ __ ] market crashed and I'm
like I had been paying I've been paying
into principle I never listened to these
[ __ ] guys eleven percent no you're
not first of all and second of all I
want to just pay this off so the [ __ ]
bank doesn't keep taking interest here's
the thing though is that okay so I agree
with you about paying the principal it's
nice to own the thing you know like
great now that my money is in the house
right but the thing is people say the
value of homes go up over time they
actually don't historically it tracks
perfectly with inflation and if you
think about it like if you've got a
house right and three people can live in
the house right thirty years from now
three people are still going to be able
to live in that house the value hasn't
gone up the amount of people that can
house is the same right right in fact
you've had to put money into it to stop
it from depreciating to fix it you know
toilet breaks you have to put money into
the house so the actual real world value
doesn't go up if you put the money in
the stock market instead the stock
market actually does go up over time so
it's not a waste of money but your your
one dollar is basically gonna stay one
dollar when you put in stock market just
scares me too much because there's just
too much of a [ __ ] you like I lost some
money when it
blue chips what's that I I lost some
money when it crashed but not nearly as
much as I would if I had listened to all
these [ __ ] dumb financial experts I
would have lost a lot more money it also
depends when you sell a house cuz you
could be in a recession you could have
bored over 500 grand yeah and six years
later it's only worth 350 and market and
you got a sell if you get some other job
somewhere so you know 150 right off the
top and a lot of people who say oh the
value of my house went up well that's
because they got lucky and they bought
in the right area of course in a certain
area can go up and down a lot and they
say you know someone people come to my
house it doubled in value I made so much
money yeah well you got you got lucky
but historically and over the whole
country see for me I just bought a place
I'm worth buying a place now in there
building next door a Plum Island
warehouse oh that's what you gotta watch
out for how much time you spend
researching these shows because there
are people all the time yeah they're
people that would come in and have this
conversation because they just host you
know a real estate show right like a
guys who just sell houses on TV those
are the guys that have this conversation
but you know all this information that's
in your head
you've got twenty two minutes out of it
a few years ago yeah and it's all and
now you got to just move on to the next
thing and the next thing in there I mean
we do 16 episodes a year I'm in the
writers room and the research room for
you know all of it and I'm you know
choosing the topics with with our staff
and everything and yeah I mean we
research every topic every topic gets
about three weeks of pure research then
we start writing it and then it's about
a month and a half two months of writing
and then we we're having it with experts
and stuff like that it's about the we
make about the hardest to make show on
TV it's like people who our staff is
like after they after they get the job
they're like what the [ __ ] are we doing
this is crazy but yeah I mean I don't
claim to be an expert on any specific
topic that we do but I've dived into
enough to get like our you know good
layman's understanding and then I talked
to real experts who we then bring on the
show so were you always thinking we're
gonna do stuff that is also political on
this show because in the beginning like
I think doing malls
and doing houses and doing like stuff
that people just interact with on a
daily basis that's one thing but when
you start jumping in you do the
immigration episode you get the gun
episode that's those are the topics that
and you take a point of view based on
facts or whatever it's based on yeah
people are gonna get emotional and they
sure do think that you're biased I mean
so this is crazy our gun episode Adam
runs guns was our season premiere it
aired on Tuesday and someone tweeted one
of these like conservative meme accounts
with like 150,000 followers
retweeted my announcement hey guys tune
in to the show in half an hour she
retweeted and said you know oh this this
is about to air on truTV and it's
liberal propaganda and it's destroying
our constitution and I'm worried about
her come right so like you've been even
seen the episode is not it's not an
anti-gun episode it corrects you know
misconceptions from you know that people
from all walks have and you know we
don't come you know we don't go and say
take the guns away right we have a much
more like nuanced take that comes from
like our deep research on it and so yeah
people are so emotional about that
they'll have that immediate reaction you
know when we started doing the show I
said we'll never I literally said we
will never do Adam ruins guns because
those are the topics where you know
there's certain topics that are like the
fault lines of American society where
people as soon as you say I'm doing
episode of guns they're like well you
better say what I [ __ ] will ya or I'm
gonna change the channel immediately or
abortion anything like that yeah like
that and I was like I want to hit him
where they're not looking and by the way
something is Pleasant Adam should not
ruin abortion everybody loves abortion
abortion right but I you know we I want
to do topics where you know people don't
have such strong feelings about so their
their minds are more open right but as
we started doing the show more and more
we said hey we got pretty good at this
we've got we've done more and more
divisive topics we think we can do it in
a way we think we can make an episode
where anyone no matter what their
starting position is on guns can watch
the episode and be entertained and also
you know be challenged right like we
challenge everybody on the show would
you ever come back and do an episode
that it's the opposite taking what you
had the first time that's a really good
question you should do and Adam ruins
Adam right Emily Emily ruins Adam ruins
ever
whoo Emily is my frequent my frequent
guest star who I am normally ruining
things for her we did an episode where
she came in and corrected a lot of the
mistakes we had made on the show before
we're like certain yeah I mean you know
you're gonna make mistakes right when
you're when you're learning when you're
you you know you can never do the
research perfectly and there have even
been topics where you know new
information has come out since we've
done it that's sort of like what's one
of you that got ruined
one was for instance we did a we did a
thing on forensic science on how like
most forensic science is like
pseudoscience fingerprints
you know crime-scene analyses stuff like
that it's really just sort of like a lot
of it's like mumbo-jumbo that like you
know detectives do that they learn from
the older detective but like no
scientist ever invented it it's just
like this is what the cops do right and
at the end we say hey DNA evidence
doesn't have these problems DNA evidence
is actually science back well it turns
out that in recent years they found that
DNA evidence does have problems as well
there's like contaminated samples
there's you know like bad labs and stuff
like that so it just because something
is DNA evidence we can't say oh yeah
that's that's totally good too if you're
on a jury and you know the the
prosecutors like well we got the DNA you
should be questioning of that just like
you would have any the best evidence you
can have in a trial is eyewitness
account you know let me tell you have
you done any episodes where you're
sitting there and like after the
research and you're writing where you go
like I didn't want to I didn't want this
to be a shitty thing you know I mean I
just wanted to have a simple life where
I could go and enjoy this and now all
I'm thinking about is that it's garbage
is hard it's hard man I mean I I'm a big
fan of the Olympics I really love the
Leela that's my favorite sporting event
and we have an episode coming up later
this year about how bad the Olympics are
the athletes are like completely
exploited by the IOC it's really bad for
the host cities like the whole thing is
a big it's it's almost a big money
laundering scheme on the part of it you
know like the the developers in the
cities and the IOC and the sponsors are
raking in so much money you know apart
from Michael Phelps the athletes make
jack [ __ ] yeah and it's it's up there
with the NCAA in terms of you know how
bad it is and I you know I didn't grow
up in an area where college sports were
big so like you know I know the truth
about the NCAA
bothered me that much the Olympics I'm
like I still want to watch it you know
and and but I I know it I know that now
and I don't know I just got to figure
that out for myself like how I'm gonna
feel of it I hope there's nothing wrong
with the curling division that's my
favorite like oh yeah sexy me no that's
the one ethical part of the Olympics is
curling I can guarantee you that madam
you do an episode on a Halloween yeah we
didn't never said in Halloween how do
you ruin that they're already aired
obviously right yeah that air we did
that one last year hallow the one on
Halloween let's see people poisoning
candy never happened never been erasable
yeah but it's like every single year the
news stories about like make sure you
check the candy etc.etc part of that we
did were the world's the War of the
Worlds story about how you know
everybody everybody panicked when they
heard the radio show that didn't that
never happens is the newspapers at the
time were terrified of the radio they
thought the radio was gonna kill their
business and they were like all this bad
information out on the radio like
newspapers people should be sick when
the newspapers and so when that show
came out they were like the radio
deceived people and they panicked and
ran into the streets and they like
published these stories about how the
evil radio had tricked people themselves
cuz Orson Welles I loved worse than
women I like now I don't like him as
much you know me neither he didn't trick
everybody it's a pretty it's a pretty
light story for Citizen Kane yeah I have
heard a good movie yeah yeah great great
but you're saying that people turned on
the radio and they were like oh this is
just a sci-fi show yeah I mean people
were maybe would have been a little
confused but it was aliens
it wasn't mass panic there were people
running around grabbing their shotguns
and shooting each other no that's a
bummer I thought maybe they turned it on
I thought it was the news we were
talking about yeah me too
we were talking about Buzz Aldrin
earlier and how just grouchy and annoyed
he is because everybody just asking the
same dumb questions all the time do you
have you gotten to a place because the
show is like hugely popular yeah have
you gotten to a place where people are
just coming up to you and asking for
your take on things or hey what about
this hey and you ruin this yeah you
haven't researched anything they just
want to know that you assume that it's
all in your head I mean like three
months after the show premiered somebody
tweeted
me and they were like hey what kind of
which gas should I get at the gas
station is the high-octane good or not
as I don't know right that's not
something I've looked into but yeah me
it's it's kind of weird as a comedian to
be you know someone who people like are
curious about what they you know like
hey tell me if this is good or not right
um but you know most of the time it's
people come saying like hey you should
do this on the show you should cover
this on the show which is nice that
people like they want to see us like
break something down we're doing more
sketch or stand up before you do this I
did both and that's why the show is what
it is I got started doing sketch comedy
like the early days of video internet
video and yeah I was doing stuff at UCB
and then I started I got into stand-up
after doing a sketch for like 6 or 7
years and I just fell in love with it I
was like oh wait this is how I like to
be funny is just myself you know being
with the people hey here's something I
learned and I was working at College
Humor at the time and I just started
combining those two things which is why
the show is like me you know talking
direct to camera doing jokes but then
also like I will set up a joke and we'll
finish it with a sketch in the
background
Nancy's hard which is really hard you're
lying on other people oh yeah and people
thrown out ideas and it's [ __ ] very
difficult you do these things just to go
for the joke but sometimes that will
just ruin at the moment of what you're
doing yes do you when you're doing
stand-up now do you do stand-up that
relates to the show because I would am
not in the same you but you know what
I'm saying like where you're yeah
ruining quote-unquote things because I
would imagine that otherwise people are
stoned showing up at your standup going
likewise this just jokes you know I have
like a I have like my our act that I do
and I have done we have done shows
they've been billed as Adam ruins
everything live and then I do that act
and then people are like I thought you
were gonna ruin stuff a little bit
people enjoy the show but you know I
like to learn things and also like you
know our show's popular with kids which
surprised me I never expected to beat on
a 10:00 p.m. you know I was like we're
making an adult the sketch show and you
know kids really started like glomming
onto it because they love to learn and
stuff and now occasionally I'll be like
10 year-olds at my at the comedy club to
perform and so then I'm doing like my
you know blue material and [ __ ] but so
now the material that I'm working on
that I'm going to be touring
20:19 is I'm really trying to combine
more information and comedy in the way
that I do on the TV show just cuz that's
what people know me for that's what I
like doing and there isn't really
anybody else doing it who's like hey
here come see an hour comedy show where
there's gonna be a ton of jokes but
you're gonna learn some amazing
information send it's there called Adam
ruins everything people know that it's
new episodes are Tuesdays at 10 o'clock
on truTV and Adam Conover on Twitter
just your name yeah yeah I'll bring
Howie in he's here or do you bring do
you want to just bring him in because
he's here are you staying for a little
bit yeah yeah you got it we still got a
couple minutes for that but how it
should join us
Howie Mandel's uh because we're not
gonna break you yeah there's no reason
to yeah bring in Howie Mandel um yeah I
would I would think but you've you've
you've do you ever feel like you're
pegged into this corner where you're now
responsible for information yeah I mean
I mean I put myself there you know come
on in Howie Howie please hey come on do
you know Adam from Adam ruins everything
right right sit down you were in the
same jack guys so you wear that jacket
last night at the tree-lighting what do
you bring er you sure I just noticed the
jacket there's the orange side is a nice
jacket it is I'll be honestly I'm also
wearing the same Underpants okay good he
just came right here how he switch
jackets it's a nice jacket in New York
he's not gonna go I better wear this one
today
sometimes people wear jackets just for
television Jen I would know an hour on
TV no he has one jacket in pack two
jackets go I'm gonna wear this one on
television shows has wardrobe sometimes
there was a great anything Jim will
experiments everything there wasn't what
Adam there was a great moment at the
tree-lighting last night but I turn it
on I was watching and how he's there and
it's live right and you're doing crowd
work and and you want to like do a bit
right and he looks at this woman and he
goes can I do something nice for you and
then we'll he goes no I know
like easy he's a process for a minute he
does a little thing and then you go back
to the woman and you're like no really
I'd like to do something nice is that
okay and the woman goes no thanks I'm
fine
so then how is it's NBC it's
tree-lighting he has to find in an
instant another person I know so he can
do the bit what did you do
it was nice always just we were I was
just sharing STDs just giving people
better seats I don't know I don't
remember exactly what I did I don't
remember but I do remember that she said
no to me I don't know what but it's but
that made it that makes for later great
it made for live it made for I'm very
excited to be here I'm fans everybody
was for so long I used to watch Bobby's
world when I was a kid I love that show
so much thank you buddy I used to do
Bobby's world when you were a kid and
now as a comedian now in the position
where I get to meet like you know comedy
heroes of mine and I never know where to
bring it up because I want to point out
that someone's older than me but at the
same time I want say I love your were
late yeah well he ruined it that's what
I do so what I do I'm the [ __ ] you on
every situation but obviously it's
complimentary
no I'm feel complimented and it was good
it's kind of a yin to the yang right I
walked in and rather than hello you when
you're wearing the same jacket doesn't
matter what I'm wearing on a radio show
look it's a nice jacket I wouldn't have
complimented the jacket if I knew it was
gonna become this whole thing kind of
weird you can bring up water that's what
you were that's not the way I told you I
was watching the tree-lighting who
brought us today I was here I speak to
same language as you I understand what
you were saying but I just hello good
morning thanks for being here oh it's a
jab for no reason this is making me feel
better for my rudeness is that gonna go
good
did you do that was rude I don't want to
bring it up again bring it up okay well
I pointed out our age difference
it was the Bobby's world and yeah you
seemed a little you seemed a little
unhappy that I did well you know today's
my birthday oh yeah thank you I want to
buy him a new jacket what an exciting
time to be you that it's your birthday
you're lighting up the Christmas tree
dealer no deals coming back
you got a great jacket just let me know
you got that meet Adam ruins everything
it's an incredible time to be how he
made data for my birthday he was an
infant I am 35 years old oh you are a
kid your same age in my kids yeah oh boy
no that's a girl so how what are you
doing for your birthday anything
specially after press I'm right here
no I this point I don't really I'm
throwing myself I'm not supposed to say
but I'm not up this early so I won't
listen to this I'm throwing myself a
little surprise party oh that's lovely
yeah wait what time that's that then
you're gonna were in the word surprise
but I haven't told anybody and when I
get back to the hotel room I'm not I'm
gonna like hide behind the door and wait
for me and then when I come in it's
gonna surprise my birthday jacket right
it's a great jacket that's all I meant
and Florentine really turned it into
something negative and no cuz you just
you just walked and you didn't mean to
revisit no no but I'm hello yeah how are
you doing Hallie oh I'm doing good I bet
you're doing good I'm good well it's my
birthday it is your birthday you get to
be here with Jim Norton of course the
man who invented chip who I know love I
love that item we didn't talk about that
afterwards no I don't want to bother you
because I saw you a Montreal and I don't
like to harp on things and it was good
to see you but yeah I appreciate you
like you that I don't my body so I mean
July is that what you're
I didn't want to bother you I said call
me let's try to do chip let's see if we
can expand on it and he didn't ok I want
to bother you alright we work in show
business I know what are you doing well
you know I'm on the fringe
I'll give how are your call I mean how I
develop shows that's what you do I tried
to write yes that people don't call what
can you develop right you can't exactly
you can't develop I said you know and I
give you an opportunity all right the
years not over I thought before the end
of the eye like a bird in the hand I
guess it depends on what you do with it
a bird in the hand that it used to be
tuna tuna mouse what does hurt that's
like the seventies yes but I didn't
remember you would that bother you if
you lowered a woman's pants and there
was two birds in there how did you
become aware of wild chip-chip person
Howie Mandel because here's what
happened last time you were in studio we
did the whole interview and after the
show is when you said you know I love
chip-chip person and all of us were like
oh no this is the last thing we need is
what is how did I become a mime online I
mean well let's not pretend like chip is
this like you know [ __ ] come on he's
a juggernaut how many followers does
that have did well how do you put it up
on yours
yes I'm follow you the animation so I
follow him I see on Instagram mm-hmm
yeah and then he puts it up on Instagram
I think that's where I saw it I see yes
I see and you look at this and you're
like this is genius this is brilliant
this is cheb thought it's funny I don't
think it's funny look it's funny but I
don't you don't understand I don't like
this is me Sam ruins chip because you
don't understand the level that chip
chip delayed my contract negotiations
with Sirius XM for a month like chip has
infected all of our lives it's not
something
just exists and we can enjoy it he is is
slowly killing Jim it did actually wrote
a contract negotiation oh it's
interesting for somebody that has such a
vile reaction to it you've said the word
chip probably like 30 times in the last
minute and I didn't bring it up you
brought up too I said the last time you
were here you brought up chip you know
chip you know how much chip bothers me
chip is what I wanted the chip chip
sure I think it's fast chip I don't want
to chip and that's all I hear and I
don't even hear the words between chip I
don't hear gotta say though isn't it
it's a fun word to say yep I feel good
it'll be viral feels good coming out
every single one of those should have
had it what's that after it though I
think of the audience first and the
audience loves chip and so I think that
the audience would find it fascinating
and entertaining that you like them are
a fan of chip trip person I am
that's and I'm a one with the people
right at my finger on the pulse well I
don't have my finger on anything I don't
like to take any now have you where's
the last time you shook somebody's hand
I know what happened something to reflux
if somebody just that like well
sometimes I'll grab somebody's elbow and
hold their hand up in the air and shake
it like I won't put my hand on their
hand to shake it I don't even understand
what that like why nice to meet you
usually you're shaking somebody's hand
that you're just approaching you don't
know where they've been what they've
done you probably don't even know
there's the filthiest part of their body
it really is yeah they cover your mouth
we're taught from the time we're
children to cover our mouth so that our
snot ends up you know in our hands yeah
and you go and your name is and then you
reach out I just need to touch you your
name is you don't you shouldn't this is
this is why everybody I mean I give them
a kiss as soon as I mean it's just a
little a little peck yeah a little peck
but not nonetheless not to be creepy I
like to kiss them between the nose and
upper lip
[Laughter]
people say can I shake your hand you
just go now I don't shake hands just
that's it I mean literally I stuck my
hand out and then he gave me the fish oh
yeah this one we're doing what we do
know because I know how to follow social
cues as I've seen a fist I'll give it a
fist right you know what's weird that
that now I've done this on you know for
a while and people know that I'm a
germaphobe and it fits but there was
many years where I would put out the
fist and then people come on I'll just
do this they don't know what to do with
it so they would like I'd have the fist
out and they'd extend the index finger
and they'd hold of yes turn around and
grab their ankles I guess there are some
things you can do with that fist of
course than a handshake which leads me
to tell you that my dealer No Deal
holiday special the good feeling and big
money and hot women that we've always
had on the show it's be it's stunning
like they'd really decorated it and it's
a million dollars and it's this Monday
right after the voice Deal or No Deal
10th anniversary holiday special and
then launches Wednesday after that on
CNBC in primetime but the Monday show is
on NBC proper that's big yes yeah yes
properly yes it's huge it's a big
special
yeah well relaunch this fascinating
wonderful weird game has it been no how
long has it been since has been on 10
years I will say the 10th anniversary
special Oh 10 that it has been 10 years
since I've been on yeah 10 straight
years well no how did it come back like
it's so weird to get something back on
the air when it's gone you know it's
weird somebody saw me from CNBC in the
street wearing the same jacket I was
wearing people at CNBC said Oh
we should relaunch the show see good
things happen this is a it's not an
insult it's a good how often are you
doing stand-up Oh more than you know a
hundred-and-something night see oh you
really are you're out there we do all
the time I've never stopped doing that
after you do two shows in one night ever
you just do two one I'll do more than
two some well when I'm out and doing
theaters and stuff probably mostly one
sometimes two and then if I'm not going
home that night I find out if there's a
club in town and I'll go drop in on the
I like I love just hanging out on stage
do you do well sitting quietly or does
your brain drive you crazy
that's how do you know that yes I don't
know you don't do I think you know well
yeah no there can be no quiet time there
is no quiet time I try to go to places
where it's noisy on the outside so that
it's not noisy on my inside really yes
so you don't like those moat like you're
not a meditation guy oh no no no that
just gives that that's a better echo
chamber for the voices in my I don't
want to be quiet do you leave the TV on
when you go to sleep play on the
background yeah do you really yes noise
I can't sleep like that at all when
you're creating something if you're
writing do you have to be someone with
there's a little background noise like
if you're gonna read see you in a write
a script or whatever do you have this
could you sit and total quieter you have
to go to like two restaurant or there's
some kind of background sound no and no
so if I'm not that disciplined where I
can sit down and and write something so
[ __ ] just comes to me all day and then
I'll put now I put it into my into my
phone right and then hopefully the
people around me are nice enough to help
me organize whatever [ __ ] I had but for
years like when I was doing comedy in
the 70s I would always just have little
pieces I didn't even have the
organization scale to get a pad like a
little a matchbox and a piece of toilet
paper and and then in the morning I'd
wake up and there's a nightstand and
it's a you know [ __ ] I go what I
don't even remember what that but I'm
sure I'm gonna follow my career next
step
so what happens when the when the head
is left alone what are the thoughts that
you're trying to is it anxiety is it
what is it it's a level it could be
anxiety it could be the depression it's
just dark and or it could be a you know
a reoccurring thought that just keeps
coming back that makes no sense to me
you know that I can't I see tap
something a couple of you know I have
OCD and rank xiety I'm a mess isn't any
better than it was he talked about a lot
to help it at all yeah it was better
before I walked in the room sometimes
good I know I'm reeling out-of-control
middle right fingers mail wait well this
is my birthday and I feel like I'm
closer to my death day yeah he walked in
and hissed at him he feels his jacket
has been mocked he's been called old and
now you're encouraging him to start town
I'm not actually I understand a certain
part of that craze is not good no I'm
okay I'm medicated so far jim Florentine
is your only ally in this room look how
he so freaked out they took his coat off
[Laughter]
just to make sure next time we do to
show you don't wear that hoodie because
Sam's gonna remember it it's just a nice
jacket why didn't you start with that
that's a good point it's not a good
clothes I didn't know how sensitive I
were about the jacket I'm not you see
how are you you seem very sensitive Tom
you can't get more than I brought up
chip not true yeah go ahead you didn't
say Jack was nice you just said hey you
wore at you yesterday you guys jump down
my throat
that's the thing I saw TV that's the TV
thing you saw yesterday that specific
jacket again I told you I was
entertained by something you did it was
the whole thing it was great and I'm
excited about Deal or No Deal
i watch CNBC all the time because I
watched the shark tank marathons yeah
and I watched the profit those are two
of my favorite shows and the fact that
they're on and a lot of times I get
annoyed when I hear there are other
shows on CNBC because what they did put
marathons on all the time it's a perfect
place for us but I saw a deal or no deal
because they run the camera
was constantly in number one I got happy
because I said they're putting some
promotion behind this this is greatly
are and number two I knew immediately if
I find out there's a deal of No Deal
marathon canceling my Shark Tank
Marathon I'm still gonna be happy cuz
Deal or No Deal is great and I'm glad I
think we can all live together as one I
don't know that any marathons are gonna
be canceled but I do have a merit I mean
that next on December 5th it's gonna run
from I saw they ads on CNBC hmm I'm on
from 8 a.m. to 2 a.m. to 2 a.m. that's
how they run them that's great six hours
that's what I said six hours of me
that's a lot of me
my wife actually said me I hope six
hours that's what she does to write they
do they do they figure out okay we
always show that people like they tune
in they're not gonna change the channel
if just another episode comes out like
every cable channels become on-demand
you know because we're a Netflix world
and so like truTV is you know 22 hours
of the day it's the Impractical Jokers
which is a wonderful show yeah and then
people tune everything practical jokers
and then after a while my show comes on
and they stick around for hopefully it's
like the best lead-in ever because
people just want that thing that they
that they want their have a big
billboard on link Lancashire we do we do
that yeah we aren't we are advertising
right now Lankershim I see your face on
that cuz it make you feel when you see a
good or bad what you know it's weird
in the Billboard yeah are you not
wearing this jacket
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we all do it right you all wear the same
jacket I get excited by it I'm like oh
yeah it's real life I know the guy from
my box on TV is now in front of me it's
exciting
look there it is this year that's last
year's toy it's old hat boy two years
ago this is a writer I see them in the
in the subway all the time I was dead
right now you know to be on Google
Images give a favorite episode of Adam
ruins everything I know you watched a
whole bunch of them yes with it what did
you like cruise ships cruise ship you
know that's such a good guest we've
never done it our writers room about 10
or 11 times so yeah it's you know I
applaud you for the effort it was you so
close so I be told in my ears if this is
true information that Adam and Jim have
to leave but how he can stay
I can stay but but when you say I'm
being told in my ears
in my ears like if somebody wanted to
communicate with you is there another
[Laughter]
where you going this is I think I think
we're just forcing us to leave the
building
yeah I don't want to hold you against
your will I'd love for you both to stay
but if this is factual I don't want to
hold you against your will you know
what's weird that you know and I don't
know that people know this is serious I
listen to you guys thank you on the air
but if you listen to Sirius you know you
just switch you can switch channels you
go okay I don't want to listen to comedy
and we're in Wireless the country or I
want to listen to but they don't realize
that all those people are just three
feet from us thinking I'm listening to a
whole new world right in the next window
there's some guys sway is right there
Eminem studio a shade 45 is right next
door done like if you got tired of us
and turned over to sway we could just as
quickly just walk over to sway studio
and be on that show - do you know that
I'm doing that next is that yes I'm just
waiting I've signal to the people
I'm with to bring me a new jacket if
Shui is not gonna be as kind as I was
your wife was watching the Christmas
tree lighting last night on TV and then
she saw the show this morning would she
say how will you wore the same jacket
two days in a row would you who is that
is the jacket my wife bought us for a
40th anniversary that's beautiful and I
am been I've been celebrating that's so
new our jacket the jacket means so that
I feel like she's always with me I'm
always wrapped up in her I know she's
listening right now oh my honey I love
you know you would say that my
girlfriend did something like that to
for our anniversary what did she give
you a new side dealer no deals come back
that shows one of the most addictive I
used to watch that for hours so Monday
I'm gonna watch the show a month so
let's tweet it each other let's do this
you can watch my show Tuesdays at 10:00
I will thank you Monday at 10:00 you
tweet with me Tuesday at 10:00 I'm gonna
watch I'm gonna make a note by the way
the first episode what are you what are
you doing on we did we did guns that
just was our premiere on Tuesday and
next week is sleep and I'm ro and sleep
oh that's great we're doing mattresses a
bunch of other crazy stuff and then
Wednesday after we're done with those
two shows we'll go to CNBC and watch No
Deal again we should do that perfect
producers the I started with the guys of
college humor and then the producers we
have on the show now came with me from
there we have a recurring character on
our show Haley Murray Norman who got her
start on Deal or No Deal
yes yeah yeah see that they got to
either go to Adam ruin Athan ruins
everything or they go to I watch that
show business synergy right right Jim
and I do not have those conversations
that's a Deal or No Deal model Yeah
right and then so they either become a
duchess or they do his show
a man
and how if you want to see me I'll be at
the tree house in Westport Connecticut
on Saturday so we need to earn the show
and we're doing anymore calls do you do
a lot I love you prank calls I haven't
done them in a while
you did yes I love prank calls and I
love pranks nobody is better at that
than you yeah I don't know I just I was
living with Jim at the time and I was
doing I know you're sitting on some gold
here and I'm like I was just doing it
just because I was bored it was funny
things but I would walk in and hear
spouts here I'm going yeah yeah in the
hallway in the office right don't you it
was addicting because I started thinking
like I would hear it in my head and do
it like I'm up I'm like that's [ __ ]
addicting there's a whole album of
telemarketer yeah but Jim was really
he's like dude this is funny stuff man
you should really start recording this
time I didn't I was just playing around
a phone and [ __ ] and then and then Stern
started playing I'm gonna just blow up
from there Jim got a show coming on
Comedy Central you know it's happy for
him yeah you and Jim got to do a show
with mm yeah you got you were happy I
was yeah yeah yeah that's irony right oh
yeah but I mean he's my friend so he my
first paid gig and comedy
really I probably be a common poster for
Jeb you 1990 how long have you been
doing comedy in 89 90 89 like six months
before Jim yeah yeah you guys are young
when the first time I met you was on
mouth crowd that's right they freaked
you out they told you I date freaking
out Colin in the rifleman how does it
make you feel that how he was like yeah
that's that's right I believe it I
remember that no no I remember that
because I really was freaked out yeah he
was a young comic you know and we have
him and he does he has AIDS and he does
and you'll be sitting with him now yeah
I remember our first picture together we
were standing both of our hands behind
our back
and we were far apart it was it was very
funny did it come up on the air or is
that just for your own um no that was
for their enjoyment of watching me yeah
I didn't bring it up I thought I thought
and you were never they never kind of
smart and you up to it on the air at all
no it was just a fun thing to do I think
you realized it was alive when you saw
me ten years later and I was okay
although you've lost weight but yeah
sure it's not good no I'm not always
good would you be are you sticking
around yeah I got a rock so he's in a
Ted Nugent so that's goodbye right like
when you say are you sticking around
what if he said yeah yeah you welcome to
yeah believe I love him you're going to
Ted Nugent he's got an interview before
I do a show on Ozzy's boneyard to hard
rock yeah right I'm interviewing him for
uh and tear so can you all right
everybody's got a lot going on Howie
everybody I mean not as much as you are
well it's starting to make me feel bad
cuz everybody's got places to go and I
got nothing
you just got here though they were here
before you that's true he hadn't came in
at 9:30 a.m. Jim's been here since 7:00
plus I don't know if you heard but
Monday on an NBC it's the 10th
anniversary of Deal or No Deal and then
Wednesday you're gonna become a fixture
of CNBC when Deal or No Deal comes back
to be an even bigger phenomenon than it
ever was and I thank you for that and
you know what you make a shitty segue
sound so smooth and work you very much
thank you did it by such grace and I
think listeners are going that just
flows right but it doesn't well you if
you wrote down if you wrote it down and
you read it you'd go am i missing a page
right but I wish you hadn't pointed that
out because then the listeners never
would have well your segue is like my
jacket I deserved it thank you for TV
thank you yes how is good meeting you
good meeting you know I never met him I
listen to him I love prank calls I
listen to a comedy club yeah we at the
comedy club yeah oh wow yeah I did like
the opening weekend Nana na na say oh
well thank you look club and a see ya at
the Hard Rock cool it's call right I
forget what's called it's called why
don't you know that Jim Howie Mandel's
comedy call right right you didn't know
that I did not know it's great yeah
I got out of my club owner possible and
I've got a club and a festival yeah like
a game show but you're a comedian now I
trust a comedian on probably a festival
more than anybody else I have a club I
have a
of all I have a game show I'm on it's
gonna be on NBC one jacket one Jack with
just the one it's a nice jacket it is
what are you still doing America's Got
Talent - yeah I'm doing America's Got
Talent and I got it America's Got Talent
champions comes on in January I got a
I'll come back and talk to you I got a
comedy special coming out next year an F
let Monday no no no it's just coming out
okay yeah it's not I'm not on anything I
brought it and I'm just gonna it's on
loose-leaf paper and whoever passes me
is I'm gonna just share it he's a
cordless Mike when you work or do you
hold him like well I'm like your head -
headset mic or hold mic I I used to use
the headset because I you know I had a
lot of gestures I don't like that
because it was like I just uh I felt
like I was in a noxious drive-through
person you know think you're ordered
right right or an air traffic controller
the gun rogue so I just I just have a I
hold a mic there's no cord on it okay do
you bring your own mic when you work no
do you well I know because you don't
like to I'm saying you might not like
your microphones are discussed they're
dirty they are I don't but I just don't
shake hands I will touch things okay I
have a it doesn't make sense but I just
don't shake hands and I do use the
microphone
I don't lick it I will not lick it
anymore I've seen comics do that I start
college did some blow job put the mic in
her mouth it's the worst thing I've ever
seen she it was a she yeah what but she
put things in their mouth
so why respected with her ability
because there are other there are other
comics that put dicks in their mouth
plenty of them with her it was more the
the idea that you put that disgusting
microphone that people are coughing into
and talking have you ever been an
iterate about all the things you've done
with your dick oh boy yeah I understand
there's a lot of there's a lot of you
for anything like when you're doing
comedy do you bring a cordless dick with
you or do you well so to speak yeah it's
got a belt on it I'll ask her to Lera -
have you ever been in a radio studio
speaking of microphones where a host has
their initials written on the windscreen
of their mic the way a kindergartener
rights on their initials on a toy I like
to use my own mic I'm not you know I'm
not crazy germaphobic but I don't want
some
else's mouth stuff in my microphone so
why don't just carry your own foam they
look for people that don't know there's
a piece of foam right this is called a
wind guard windscreen
yeah but how windy does it get in here
that you need to scream very windy
because we blow and then like a true
professionally held for the laughs and
the laughs he was waiting for ya but no
the and the initials are already on the
microphone yeah but he has so little
trust for the stats one day in the
middle of the show he just picked up a
sharpie and started writing very audibly
into the microphone I just didn't I just
didn't trust that the our guy would
would do this properly what's new wood
right that's your fun this is my you
know this is the way I like my Jays this
is the way I like my end that's what he
needed yeah when did you start what year
did you start comedy 77 78 77 70 it's
been 40 years don't want comedy clubs
then so what were you doing it no yeah
Jackson in Toronto I went on an amateur
night on a dare and I didn't even aspire
to be a comedian in fact if anybody
watches on YouTube like my my first like
my the way I fell in the comedy somebody
said you should get up and do it I go
watch this I'm gonna do it cuz I had a
normal retail job and I went up they
went ladies and gentlemen Howie Mandel
and and I woke up and I think okay this
is the joke and then I realized [ __ ]
there's a light there's a mic and people
are standing there staring at me kind of
like you guys are right now
and I had nothing and I go and and
nerves kicked in and my act was very
different there but it was it was real
and I would go okay okay okay all right
okay okay and then they would start
giggling at the okay and I'd go what
what what okay oh wait here okay okay
and the the fact that I had nothing and
I had all that energy was it was getting
laughs and then I had my I put my hands
in my pocket and had a rubber glove
because I don't like I was still I have
the same issues today and I don't carry
you know I didn't want to touch things
so then I say okay okay and like an
idiot I just pulled the glove over my
head and I started breathing
and the fingers were going up and down
and I'm going what what and then I
thought about my hand crowd applauds and
I go oh that's a worth an applause
that's it
that'll be my closer so it's mostly
crowd I do a lot of crowd work too I
just well I guess what I'm trying to say
is I had nothing I don't know that it
changes today I don't know how much I
actually have but I just went up there
and and then I went down to California
on separate business and I had met
comics at yuk-yuks and I got on at the
comedy store and there was a producer in
the audience from the comedy game show
called make me laugh and I did that in
1978 went back and continued in a normal
job in in Toronto Canada and I started
getting calls because we didn't have
make me laugh in Canada and I got a call
from Merv Griffin and Mike Douglas and I
went down and I did a Mike Douglas show
on the Merv Griffin ago Wow yeah and
then on Merv on Merv Griffin gene
Simmons had been watching gene Simmons
of KISS fame of course who at the time
was living with his girlfriend who
happens to be Diana Ross Wow and he
called I saw her last night Tim yeah she
was on the show yeah I just saw her in
the lobby she's wearing the same but
anyway and he said will you open for my
girlfriend at the at Caesars and I
didn't really have an act and I went to
Caesars and became Diana Ross's opening
it oh wow yeah and then I ended up doing
like 14 Merv Griffin's and and a bunch
of Mike Douglass's and I got on the
young comedians special in 1980 on
comedians it was me Jerry Seinfeld
Richard Lewis Harry Anderson and there
was a lady can't remember she's an
impressionist but I forget her name and
it was hosted by The Smothers Brothers
and then that thing just a you know
exactly 7th annual or less maybe 6th 5th
yeah